بدورها قالت وزيره الخارجيه البلجيكيه ان
بلجيكا جمدت اصولا روسيا ضخمه اضافت في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان استخدام هذه الاصول
في اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا يحتاج لاطار
قانوني وهو ما لا يتوفر حتى الان
الاصول لاننا في وسط نظام اوروكلير الذي
يسمح بانتقال الاموال لدينا 50 مليار من
الاصول المجمده للاوليغارتيين ومئتين
مليار من المداولات عبر يوروكلير وهو نظام
في بلجيكا مقره في بلجيكا اذا السؤال هو
كيفيه فك التجميد عن هذه الاصول لدينا
حاجه الى اطار قانوني غير قائم حاليا
وبالتالي ولو كانت الفكره جذابه بان
نستخدم بعض الاموال لاعاده بناء اوكرانيا
هذا لم يتم التطرق اليه على مستوى جدول
الاعمال بسبب غياب الاطار القانوني لذلك
كما قالت وزيره الخارجيه البلجيكيه على
الدول الاوروبيه للحفاظ على وحدتها في
مواجهه روسيا ومحاربه ظاهره الافلات من
العقاب اضافت في مقابله مع الجزيره ان
البلدان الاوروبيه قد تختلف بالنظر
للتباين في سياساتها الخارجيه وميول
حكوماتها لكنها تتفق في نهايه المطر
وان يكون لدينا استراتيجيه بعيده الامل
نحن نتحدث عن اعاده البناء الان ولو ان
الحرب مستمر بقوه في الميدان نتحدث بناء
البناء التحتيه الحيويه التي تسمح
لاوكرانيا بالمقاومه نحن نتحدث عن محاربه
الافلاتي من العقاب وبلجيكا تتصرف في هذا
المجال امام المحكمه العدل الدوليه ولقد
ايضا شاركنا بعمليه بجمع الادله التي جرت
في مسرح الجريمه نحن ليس لدينا انقسام في
الموقف انتم تشرون الى هذا السؤال بشكل
متكرر ولكن اسره على اجابه طبعا هناك بعض
الاختلافات في او تنوع في وجهات النظر نحن
نتحدث عن 27 دوله
اسبانيا اليوم على سبيل المثال بواقع
او فنلندا المجر على سبيل المثال التي
تعتمد بشكل كبير على الطاقه وعلى
الاتفاقات التي ابرمتها مع روسيا طبعا
الاوضاع في البلدان تختلف ولكن في نهايه
المطاف نتفق وهذه هي النقطه المهمه